Asked all the time about our learning journals,
what I put in them, where I get the resources from.
So let's do a quick flip through
of all of the learning journals that I have,
starting with reading.
I use a reading journal to go with our read alouds.
So every time I do a chapter book read aloud with the kids,
we go through, and we will write the title,
the characters, the setting,
and my kids draw a picture.
And as I'm reading, I'm asking some comprehension questions
about things that are happening in the book,
and they will write their answer here.
Now, they will tell me their answer,
and I write it on a whiteboard,
and they use it as copywork because they are still, like,
young enough for that. My daughter is just now.
She's in second grade,
getting to the point where she is writing her own sentences.
But that's how I started with Copyworks.
And every new book that we do,
we make a little tab for the title.
They include a title picture,
and just ask some questions as we go through the books.
Next up is our anatomy journal,
and this goes with our Sassafra Science Adventure
volume 2 anatomy study. And it comes with all of these different parts,
and I just glue them in here as we go.
So this is the skeletal system that we are learning right now.
And so they'll spend one day coloring all the Pieces
and we glue them in. And as we go and we learn about different things,
they will write what they are learning right here.
And then we glued in here.
We save it all in here for the whole school year.
And then our 50 States Journal goes with our 50 states by not grass.
And we do not go in order.
We are starting with all of the states that we have been to.
So they start by writing the state name.
This is the state that I live in.
So each time I'll either do the state nickname,
the state, like when it became a state,
the state hood number. And then we include an outline of the picture
which comes with the curriculum.
And then we do pictures of anytime we've travelled.
I also try to do some type of colouring picture that I find on Google.
Uh, something that we are learning throughout this study.
And as we go, my daughter,
who is going to second grade,
will write her own captions
and my first grader will tell me a caption for the picture.
I also have these state flags that I bought on Amazon.
So every new state we add the state flag.
You can see it there.
And so it's just a fun way to keep memories together,
but also like what we're learning about throughout that state.